اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير مستمرون معكم
اعزائي المشاهدين في تغطيتنا لتطورات
الاوضاع في السودان مع استمرار الاشتباكات
والمواجهات المسلحه بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع فاليوم الثاني على
التوالي ما تزال الصوره غير واضحه حيث
يتبادل الطرفان اعلان السيطره على موقع او
مقر للطرف الاخر ومع ذلك تتجه الانظار نحو
مقر قياده الجيش والقصر الجمهوري حيث تدور
معارك عنيفه بالاسلحه الثقيله منذ ساعات
ومع زياده خطر ان يتحول الصراع الى حرب
اهليه توالت ردود الفعل الدوريه التي
تطالب باحكام العقل ووقف فوري للمواجهات
وبدء حوار يقود الى حال سلمي للازمه
الراهنه
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اعزائي المشاهدين هنالك قصف يا طالب ابراج
النيلين في الخرطوم حيث مكاتب قناه
العربيه وقناه الحدث ولكن الحمد لله يعني
دون وقوع عصابات حتى الساعه في هذه
المعلومات بالطبع في هذه الابراج مكاتب
لوسائل اعلاميه عده بينها مكتب قناه
العربيه ومكتب قناه الحدث اذا هذه الصور
للقصف
الذي
تعرضت له ابراج النيلين في الخرطوم قصف
مدفعي بالاسلحه الثقيله طاله البرجين ولكن
المعلومات افادتنا بعدم وقوع اي اصابات
اذا
هذه المشاهد نعيدها عليكم لهذا القصف الذي
طال ابراج النيلين في الخرطوم حيث مكاتب
قناه العربيه ومكاتب قناه الحدث وغيرها من
مكاتب وكالات الصحافه العربيه والعالميه
في هذا المبنى المعلومات تفيد بعدم وقوع
اصابات حتى الساعه لا نعرف مصدر هذا القصف
من اي جهه ومن اي طرف ولكن
القصف هو باسلحه ثقيله يعني من حجم الدمار
في
هذه الابراج يعني نشاهد فجوات احدثها
القصف بالطبع هذا يعني هذه الفجوات
الكبيره ليست وليده الطلقات ناريه او اعير
ناريه سواء متوسطه وخفيفه هي قذائف بطبيعه
الحال
اذا هذا القصف لابراج النيلين
من دون ان نعرف حتى الساعه
مصدر هذا القصف من اي طرف
في العاصمه الخرطوم
في هذه الاثناء اثناء الجيش السوداني على
صمود قوته وقال في بيان ان الجنديه
السوداني اثبت قدرته على التصدي لاكبر
تهديدات الامن الوطني
البيان اضاف ان ما اسماهم بالميليشيا
المتمرده وقيادتها الانتهازيه ستكون بديلا
تتوهم انها ستكون بديلا للجيش السوداني في
اشاره الى قوات الدعم السريع
هذا ورصدت الكاميرا العربيه الشوارع شبه
خاليه في مدينه ام درمان حيث تدور
اشتباكات ضاريه منذ الامس
هذا واظهر مقطع فيديو متداول لاستمرار
الاشتباكات في محيط سلاح الاشاره قرب منزل
قائد قوات الدعم السريع في منطقه كوبر
سامعين الصوت ولا ما سامعين
ضرب مكثف شديد
اتجاه اليمين المعسكر بهناك بين الحراريه
والبيوت دي
الضرب من بعدل من هناك
مربع سته
طبعا ضيفه خرطوم
حريقه كبيره شديد
باتجاه المطار والقياده العامه تحديدا
يعني
وفي المقابل نشرت قوات الدعم السريع مقطع
فيديو قالت انه من داخل اروقه القصر
الجمهوري حيث زعمت السيطره عليه وهو ما
نفاه الجيش
في العربيه
الله اكبر
اهلا وسهلا بك جديد المشهد الميداني من
عندك في هذه الاوقات طبيعه المعارك
والمواجهات وحدود سيطره كل طرف ساترك لك
الميكروفون بالصوت والصوره نزار تفضل
وانا بدوري ساترك الكاميرا لتتحدث ولتخبر
الساده المشاهدين من هنا من مروي عبر هذه
الصور الخاصه والحصريه لقناه العربيه التي
توضح عبر هذه المشاهد تتابع معي الان من
على البعد ذلك العمود لاحد المواقع داخل
قاعده مروي العسكريه هذا العمود الدخاني
قبل خمس دقائق لم نلاحظ له لكن يبدو ان
تمت اشتباكات حدثت
وعليه تمكنت بعض القوات او القوات يا اما
انها تتبع للدعم السريع او للجيش السوداني
من تدبير من تدمير احدى الاليات العسكريه
في ذلك الموقع نعيد ونؤكد بان قوات الدعم
السريع ما زالت حتى معلوماتنا الان ما
زالت توجد داخل هذه القاعده التي نراها
الان مباشره قاعده مروي الجويه العملياتيه
العسكريه
في جوانب مختلفه ومحاور مختلفه حول هذه
القاعده تتمركز قوات للجيش السوداني تحيط
بهذه القاعده بالتالي حجم الاشتباكات ربما
يتسع خلال الفتره المقبله او الساعات
المقبله اذا ما استمر الوجود المستمر
لاكثر من اربعه ايام لقوات الدعم السريع
في هذه المنطقه على صعيد اخر الصعيد
المجتمعي والصعيد الميداني والصعيد
المدنيين
اصابات مدنيين هي على حالها حتى الامس نحو
خمس اصابات ولكن وفق متابعتك يعني انت
اقرب الى الاحداث منا او حتى يعني سواء
يعني عبر الرؤيه او عبر الصوت انا مدرك
تماما انك لا تستطيع ان تتقدم اكثر بالطبع
هذه مواجهات وهذه حرب فعليه ولكن
الاشتباكات هي داخل المطار ام لا تتم من
على مبعده يعني الجيش يقصف قوات الدعم
السريع الموجوده في المطار ام لا هنالك
وحدات للجيش تمكنت من الدخول يعني
الاشتباكات داخل المطار ام لا عبر المطار
يعني القصف يتم من بعيد
ساوضح لك هذه النقطه يوم الامس عندما بدات
الاشتباكات القوات التي تتبع للدعم السريع
كانت خارج حرم قاعده مروي الجويه وكانت
قوات الجيش داخل هذه القاعده اي ان
المحاور الان تبدلت من كان بالامس في ذات
الموقع في وسط هو الان في الخارج يوم
الامس كانت قوات الدعم السريع في الخارج
وقوات الجيش داخل الموقع الرئيسي في هذه
القاعده في قلب القاعده عندما تم التبادل
وتم الاشتباك وتمت العمليه العسكريه كانت
قوات الدعم السريع تقصف وهي في الجانب
الشمالي الشرقي من القاعده اي انها خارج
حدود القاعده بصفه رسميه وقوات الجيش
السوداني قوات المسلحه كانت تقصف من داخل
القاعده العسكريه هذه هي طبيعه القصف
بعدها مباشره بعد ان تطورت العمليه
العسكريه
في اطار تكتيك انسحبت قوات الجيش السوداني
قوات المسلحه السودانيه انسحبت من هذه
القاعده وتركت قوات الدعم السريع تتعمق
اكثر في قلب هذه القاعده عليه اصبحت
الصوره كالاتي قوات الدعم السريع تسيطر
وتحتل جزء من هذه القاعده وقوات المسلحه
السودانيه خرجت في اطار الحدود الخارجيه
واحاطت من اكثر من محور القاعده لتصبح
محاطه بصوره كليه من قبل القوات المسلحه
السودانيه هذا يعني ان قوات الدعم ارادت
لو سمحت لي كم هو حجم القاعده ولماذا هي
مهمه جدا جدا بالنسبه الى الطرفين
مع العلم انها تبعد عن الخرطوم يعني كبيره
وكبيره جدا
نعم هذه القاعده تبعد نحو 400 كيلو متر من
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم شمالا هي قاعده
في الاطار الاستراتيجي والامن تعرب بانها
قاعده عملياتيه عملياتيه اي انها تتم
عبرها العمليات العسكريه العمليات الجويه
هي تمتد في مساحه 18 كيلومتر بداخلها مدرج
بطول 4 كيلومترات يستخدم في العمليات
العسكريه اسراب من الطيران الجيش السوداني
دائما ما يتمركز في هذه القاعده التي
تراها الان هي واحده من عديد القواعد
الموجوده في السودان هنالك قواعد في
الجانب الشرقي من البلاد قواعد في وسط
البلاد قواعد في جنوب البلاد قواعد في
الخرطوم وهذه القاعده التي توصف دائما في
عرف القوات المسلحه بانها قاعده
استراتيجيه استراتيجيه لانها تطل على
مناطق حيويه تطل على بعد مئات الكيلومترات
من البحر الاحمر البحر الاحمر تعطيل ايضا
على الحدود مع مصر جمهوريه مصر العربيه
ليست بعيده من شواطئ البحر الاحمر ليست
بعيده من البحر الابيض البحر الاحمر البحر
الابيض كل هذه المناطق وجود التمارين
العسكريه بين الجيش السوداني وبين قوات
اقليميه سواء كان مصر او المملكه العربيه
السعوديه او قوات اقليميه اعطى هذه
القاعده حيويه واقطع واعطاها بعد
استراتيجي هذه القاعده مهمه لماذا مهمه
لان الجيش السوداني دائما اذا ما اراد ان
يستخدم الاسراب اسراب الطيران السوداني
استخدم الميج او مختلف الطائرات الانتينوف
او غيرها فان هذا الموقع من الاهميه بمكان
ومن السهوله ان تتحرك القوات الجويه من
هذه النقطه الى مختلف المواقع في السودان
وبسرعه وبيسر لذلك ربما
قوات الدعم السريع ان هذه القاعده مهمه
عليها ان تكون على مقربه منها عليها ان
تبسط سيطرتها عليها ان تكون اكثر قرب من
اي تحرك يمكن ان يخرج من هذه القاعده
ويمكن ان يؤثر بصوره ايجابيه للجيش وعلى
قوات الدعم السريع بصوره سلبيه هذا يعني
عندما عندما يعني تقصف قوات الجيش قوات
الدعم السريع المتواجدون المتواجدين داخل
القاعده اي اسلحه تستخدم ام لا تتم
المواجهات بالاسلحه الخفيفه والمتوسطه ام
لا يعني وفق متابعتك هنالك اسلحه ثقيله
مدفعيه
اليات مدرعه
فقط لتعطينا بعض من المعلومات
يعني يوم الامس عندما كنا نتابع وكنا على
مقربه امطار قليله من الاشتباكات من امام
البوابه الرئيسيه لهذه القاعده التي
تتابعونها الان على الهواء مباشره
الصوت الدوي الذي استمعنا اليه هو صوت
لراجمات صوت لمدفعيه ثقيله هنالك اسلحه
شخصيه اسلحه سواء كان الكلاشنكوف او الجيم
ثري كل هذه الطلقات كانت تسمع بوضوح من
هذه القاعده هذه القاعده ايضا تضم اسلحه
للقوات البريه سواء كانت الراجمات او عبر
السيارات التي تحمل الار بي جي في سيارات
الدفع الرباعي هنالك ايضا نضيف وجود لسرب
من الطيران لكن الطيران لم يتم استخدامه
في هذه العمليه الحربيه حتى الان تم
استخدامه في الخرطوم في عدد من المواقع
تقريبا في شرق السودان لكن لم يستخدم
كسلاح فعال وكسلاح حاسم في هذه الجوله وفي
هذه المعركه وفي هذه العمل هذه طبيعه الاس
التي تم استخدامها قوات الدعم السريع
دائما عندما تتحرك تتحرك باسلحه خفيفه
سواء كانت عبر قاذفات الار بي جي او
باسلحه كلاشنكوف او باسلحه او بالقذائف
خفيفه التناول التي يمكن ان تستخدم عبر
الجنود في وضعيات مختلفه وفي وضعيات
متحركه وفي وضعيه ثابته هذه هي طبيعه
الاسلحه والطبيعه الاليات التي تم
استخدامها في هذه العمليه العسكريه اما في
الخرطوم فكما تتابعون عبر النقل المباشر
وعبر الفيديوهات وعبر الصور فالدبابات
كانت حاضره القصف عبر المدفعيه كان حاضر
الضرب عبر الاسلحه الخفيفه مباشره من قبل
التجوال في مختلف الطرق في العاصمه
الخرطوم كان حاضرا هذه هي الطريقه وهذا هو
مسرح العمليات العسكريه في السودان النزار
هل يمكن تقدير حجم القوات الدعم السريع
داخل قاعده مروي يعني هل هم بالمئات ام
بالالاف وهل يمكن تاكيد ان القاعده محاصره
تماما من قبل الجيش بمعنى لا يمكن ان تصل
لقوات الدعم السريع اي امدادات من الخارج
قوات الدعم السريع وفي اطار حرب البيانات
اكدت غير مره بان وجود قوات الدعم السريع
في منطقه مروي سيعزز بقوات اضافيه ستصل
لكنها لم تحدد طبيعه هذه القوات ولم تحدد
طبيعه الاسلحه التي ستساند هذه القوات
كذلك فعل
فعلت القوات المسلحه السودانيه واشارت عبر
مصادر بانها ايضا ستعزز من وجودها في هذه
المنطقه الحيويه والاستراتيجيه في قاعده
مروي العملياتيه قوات الدعم السريع عندما
وصلت قبل قبل اربعه ايام الى هذه المنطقه
كانت في حدود
105 سيارات وصلت كل سياره تحمل نحو عشره
من جنود ومن ضباط القوات قوات الدعم
السريع وصلوا الى هذه المنطقه لدينا
معلومات خاصه
وصلتنا ايضا قبل قليل كانت تفيد بان نحو
40 سياره تتبع لقوات الدعم السريع قد ان
من احد المحاور وربما هذا المحور قد لا
يكون فيه وجود معزز من قبل قوات المسلحه
السودانيه في ذلك الجانب تلك المنطقه
منطقه الجبال وهنالك تسمى منطقه الابراج
هذه الجبال السوداء هذه الامتدادات لهذه
الجبال اذا كنت تلاحظ عبر الصوره
المصادر تقول بانها خرجت عبر اربعين سياره
مرافق لها سياره اسعاف طبي خرجت من هذه
المنطقه الى جهه معلومه اما بقيه السيارات
فهذا يعني اذا خرجت اربعين فهنالك نحو 60
او خمس ستين سياره او اليه تابعه لقوات
الدعم السريع موجوده داخل مقر هذه القاعده
العملياتيه بمدينه مروي طيب نزار نحن
نتحدث عن القاعده الجويه ولكن يعني
المباني المدنيه هي على اي مبعده من
القاعده
وداخل المناطق السكنيه
هل حدثت اشتباكات وكم كانت كم كان حجم هذه
الاشتباكات لانه في الصوره الان نحن لدينا
صوره بانوراميه للقاعده الجويه وللجال
يعني التي نشاهدها في اطار الصوره ولكن
بالنسبه الى المناطق المدنيه
على كم مبعده يعني انت وفق تقديراتك من
القاعده الجويه
نعم ساعطيك الان صوره لتوضح لك اكثر بعض
المباني المدنيه والاحياء
الو نزار نحن معك تفضل
نعم الصوره ستوضح يعني مثلا هنا ستوضح
الصوره وجود بعض الاحياء والمرافق
الاستراتيجيه في مدينه مروي هذه القرى
يعني مدينه مروي هي مدينه صغيره بها عشرات
الاحياء الصغيره هي في مقابله مباشره مع
قاعده مروي الجويه الطريقه الذي يفصل بين
الحي هو حي ام دوم هنا في هذه المدينه
وبين قاعده مروي لا يبعد اكثر من 400 متر
او 500 متر فقط من السياج الخارجي لمطار
مروي الدولي ولقاعده مروي
العملياتيه عليه او بالتالي فان وجود
المدنيين في هذه المنطقه هو وجود طبيعي
ولكن الذي هو غير طبيعي وجود هذه العمليات
في هذه المنطقه مطار مروي الدولي على مدى
السنوات الماضيه انقطع الاتصال ولكن
ساحاول ان اواصل عبر نحن نسمع تفضل نزار
الوصف انقطع الاتصال عبر الهاتف ولكن
ساواصل عبر الصوت هذه الاحياء هي متاخمه
لهذه القاعده ذكرت بانه خلال السنوات
الماضيه لم تكن هنالك اي اشكاليات امنيه
تستدعي ان يتخوف المواطنون او يبتعدون
داخل المدينه ليس هنالك من اشتباكات
الاوضاع امنه الاوضاع مستقره كل العمليات
العسكريه تتم فقط في حدود وفي عمق القاعده
العسكريه هي قاعده مروي التي تشاهدون
صورها الان لذلك اذا كنت تسمعني كنت انا
اريد ان اسالك اذا كنت تسمعني حجم الخسائر
حجم الخسائر البشريه من الطرفين نتيجه
الاشتباكات في مروي يعني الضحايا سواء
قتلى او جرحى ينقلون الى يعني المدينه
مجهزه بمستشفيات نعم استقبال مثل هكذا
حالات
نعم ان كنت قد استمعت الى السؤال والذي
يتعلق بوضعيه المدنيين في هذه العمليه
العسكريه هذا هو السؤال لا انا سالت نزار
عن حجم الخسائر البشريه حتى الساعه في
معارك مروي اذا كان لديك اي معلومات او اي
ارقام
وسالتك اذا مدينه مروي مجهزه على المستوى
الاستشفائي والطب الاستقبال الجرحى او
حالات بهذا المستوى يعني
اها
نعم نعم فهمت السؤال
الوضع الامني القى بظلاله على واقع
المدنيين
داخل الصفوف القوات المسلحه السودانيه حتى
الان لم يصدر بيان رسمي من المتحدث الرسمي
باسم الجيش السوداني او القوات المسلحه
يفصل فيه ويوضح حجم ضحايا هذه العمليه
العسكريه تحديدا هنا في مروي لكن
المعلومات الغير مؤكده وحسب المصادر
الخاصه لنا هنالك ضحايا من قبل الجيش
السوداني في هذه المعركه هنا في مروي
هنالك ايضا لكن ليس هنالك اعداد مقدره
هنالك اصابات وسط قوات القوات المسلحه
السودانيه يوم الامس احصينا نحو خمسين من
الاصابات توزعوا في مستشفي مروي العسكري
القومي هنا في مدينه مروي والبعض الاخر
نقل الى مستشفى كريمه وهو ايضا احد
المستشفيات التي تعاون مستشفى مروي
العسكري وتم تقديم العلاج وتم تقديم
الاسعافات الاطقم الطبيه في هذه المدينه
حتى اللحظه لم تشتكي من غياب بعض الادويه
او بعض المعينات في طبيعه مثل هذه الاحداث
وهذه العمليات اذا ما استدعى نقل الجرحى
او المصابين فانه سيتم نقل المصابين سواء
كان عبر طائرات الجيش السوداني او عبر
الاسعاف الخاص التابع للجيش من هذه
المدينه ومن مستشفيات المدينه مباشره الى
قاعده ام درمان الطبيه المعروفه هنالك
بالسلاح الطبي بمدينه ام درمان هذا هو حجم
الضرر وحجم ما حدث اما في الصفوف المدنيين
فحتى يوم الامس احصينا نحو خمس اصابات فقط
هذه الاصابات نتجت لتعرض مدنيين لشظايا
وصلتهم من داخل قاعده مروي العسكريه لماذا
وصلتهم لانهم كانوا يسكنون ويقطنون بالقرب
من القاعده وجودهم بالقرب من القاعده
عرضهم لهذه الشظايا التي تعرضوا لها طيب
ابقى معي نزار سنعود اليك في سياق هذه
التغطيه نزار بقداوي من مدينه مروي وكل
هذه المتابعه
هذا وحذرت قوى الحريه والتغيير من استمرار
المواجهات بين قوات الجيش والدعم السريع
وسقوط ضحايا ودعت اول حريه والتغيير
قيادات الجيش والدعم السريع الى تحكيم صوت
العقل ووقف المواجهات كما اتهمت الحريه
والتغيير فلول النظام السابق بالتعبئه
للحرب في البلاد مشدده على ضروره نبذ خطاب
الكراهيه وتاجيج الحرب ومعالجه الخلافات
عبر الحلول السياسيه
[تصفيق]
قبل الانتخابات دايرين انتخابات حره نزيهه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الى هذه المشاهد التي تردنا الان للمعارك
والمواجهات في محيط مطار الخرطوم بالطبع
الصوره غير
واضحه تماما ولكن يمكننا ان نلاحظ اعمده
الدخان في صدر الصوره
وايضا سماع حده المواجهات وهذه الزخات من
الرصاص
يعني يمكن تقدير يعني انا اسلحه متوسطه
رشاشه متوسطه وايضا سماع بعض القذائف
الصاروخيه هذه المعارك اذا في محيط مطار
الخرطوم حده المعارك
تعنف في هذه الاوقات في هذه المنطقه اذا
من محيط مطار الخرطوم بالطبع مطار الخرطوم
معطل تماما
منذ الامس
بعد الاشتباكات والمواجهات حتى يعني تم
يعني تضرر
طائرتين على الاقل في حرم المطار وايضا
يعني علق الكثير من
المسافرين
نتيجه تعطل حركه الملاحه بشكل كلي نتيجه
هذه
المواجهات اذا اعمده الدخان يمكن ان نراها
في محيط المطار نتيجه تجدد القصف
المواجهات بين الجيش السوداني بقياده
الفريقة الفتاح البرهان
وقوات الدعم السريع بقياده الجنرال محمد
حمدان حتى الساعه يعني ايضا المعلومات
متضاربه متناقضه الى حد بين الطرفين يعني
كل طرف يدعي السيطره على المواقع
الاستراتيجيه لياتي الطرف الاخر وينفي هذه
الادعاءات كما ان كل طرف ينشر فيديوهات
لتاكيد موقفه وسيطرته على بعض المواقع
الاستراتيجيه اذا هذه
الاشتباكات وهذه الصور الحصريه
للمواجهات في محيط مطار الخرطوم
الدولي المعطل والمشلول تماما بفعل هذه
المواجهات منذ يوم امس
الى القاهره الان لمزيد من المتابعه
والتحليل معي الدكتوره اسماء الحسيني وهي
مديره تحرير الاهرام والمتخصصه في الشان
الافريقي دكتوره اسماء اهلا وسهلا بك اولا
اريد تعليق منك على سير هذه المواجهات
والمعارك في يومها الثاني
وهل تعتقدين يعني ان احد الطرفين يستطيع
الحسم بسهوله ام لا هذه الحرب فتحت لتبقى
طويلا وطويلا
نعم اخي العزيز انت محق تماما في كل ما
ذهبت اليه يعني اولا يعني ارى انه هذه
الحرب الان هي حرب كارثيه بكل معنى الكلمه
على الشعب السوداني وعلى محيطه الاقليمي
وعلى المصالح الدوليه حتى في المنطقه
حرب مدمره بكل معنى الكلمه قالت المدنيين
العزله طالت المستشفيات
والمباني السكنيه وايضا
المولات التجاريه وحتى يعني مكتب قناه
العربيه لم يسلم من هذا القصف والاعلاميين
المتواجدين فيه وبالتالي هي يعني حرب تصيب
خط عشواء كل من تطاله يدها وليس في صالح
الشعب السوداني استمرار هذه الحرب واعتقد
انه
هذه الحرب يعني الجميع فيها خسران وانه لا
حسم لهذه القضيه لا لا ليست هناك معارك
تحسن الامور في السودان
يحسمها التوافق كلنا راينا حرب الجنوب
الطويله المدمره ثم انتهت بعد ذلك في
اتفاقيه السلام وكذلك في دارفور ومعارك
كبيره ويعني قلبت العديد من الشرور
للسودان في اثيوبيا المجاوره الحرب بين
المدمره الوحشيه بين الحكومه المركزيه
واقليم تجراي الان تنتهي بهذه المفاوضات
السلميه وبالتالي يجب ان نتعظ من غيرنا
وان نذهب لاحوار وحل عبر تسويه سياسيه
سلميه هل الوقت هو وقت مناسب الان لطرح اي
مبادره اي خطوه للحوار تحديدا من جميع
الدول العربيه برايك يعني اليوم كان عندها
اجتماع واصدرت بيان ام لا لا صوت الان
يعلو فوق صوت المدفع كما يقال وقد سبق
السيف العزل ان صح التعبير
نعم بالفعل الان المعارك دائره والاولويه
الاولى يجب ان تكون لوقف هذه المعارك
لاسكاد صوت البنادق والمدافع والرشاشات
والقذائف
وبعد ذلك يجب ان يكون هناك بعض الالتزام
بوقف اطلاق فوري
تدعو له وساطه من هذه الدول العربيه
وايضا تضم اطراف دوليه مهمه ومؤثره حتى
تستطيع الضغط على الطرفين اللذين لا
ينصتان لاحد الان بعد ذلك يبدا الحديث عن
حل سلمه للقضايا واعتقد انه ليس هناك اي
قضيه في السودان تستحق كل هذا القصف وكل
هذا الدمار يعني يتم دمج الدعم السريع في
عام او عامين يتفق الجميع على صيغه وسط
كان يمكن ان يتم التوصل اليها بشيء من
التنازلات بين الجميع
كل قضايا هي مطروحه للنقاش ومطروحه لمرونه
وتنازلات الاط
راف المحموم نحو معارك غير مجديه دكتوره
اسماء ولكن ما يجري الان الا يفتح الباب
واسعا جدا لمزيد من التدخل الدولي في
الشان السوداني ونكون امام سيناريو مشابه
للسيناريو الليبي يعني ستاتيكو كل طرف
يسيطر على منطقه على جزء من البلاد وتبقى
الامور معلقه الى ما لا نهايه
نعم هذا هو ما يخشى
على السودان منه ستكون لهذه الاوضاع
المختله هذه الاوضاع التي يمكن ان يعني
ينهار فيها الوضع المركزي للدوله
السودانيه في حال انتصار اي طرف من
الطرفين سيذهب الطرف الاخر ليسيطر على
المناطق التي ينتمي اليها
قبائليا وعجائريا وبالتالي سيكون هناك
بالفعل
لتمرد جديد في السودان لاشعال الاطراف
لاستعانت هذا الطرف باطراف دوليه
تكون هذا كل هذه الاوضاع بالطبع الى غير
صالح الشده ترى اسماء وانت تتحدثين يعني
حده القصف تعنف في محيط مطار الخرطوم كنا
استمعنا الى رشقات بالاسلحه الثقيله يعني
صوت الانفجارات كان مسموعا اضافه الى الرش
الرشاشه اذا المعارك تعنف في محيط المطار
وبالطبع السنه الدخان نشاهدها بشكل واضح
دكتوره اسماء هل ما يجري في السودان برايك
هو شان داخلي سوداني وخلاف داخلي على
السلطه يعني بين الطرفين ام لا يعني هذه
قراءه سطحيه ما يجري هو انعكاس
لقوى النفوذ الاقليميه والدوليه في المشهد
السوداني نعم هذا حقيقي يعني تداخلت امور
كثيره فعلا هناك تقاطعات اقليميه ودوليه
عديده
جعلت المشي يعني خلقت هذا المشهد الراهب
لكن هناك ايضا مطامع ومصالح ويعني يعني
يعني مصارعه او يعني حرب بين الاطراف على
النفوس وعلى السلطه وبالتالي نحن يعني
الان الامر لا يخص السودان وحده لانه
استقرار وسلام من السودان هو استقرار لامن
وسلام المنطقه كلها
خالي الدول المعنيه في المقام الاول هي
الدول القريبه الدكتوره اسماء ابقي ابقي
معنا اعزائي المشاهدين ساترككم الان
بالصوت والصوره مع هذه المشاهد من محيط
مطار الخرطوم حيث تعنف حده المعارك الان
[موسيقى]
اذا مع هذه المشاهد حيث تعنوا في المعارك
في هذه الاوقات اعزائي المشاهدين سواء في
محيط مطار الخرطوم او في محيط مقر القياده
العامه للقوات المسلحه ايضا في الخرطوم
يبدو ان هنالك محاوله من كل طرف للسيطره
على هذين الموقعين الاستراتيجيين بالطبع
هنالك ادعاءات لكل طرف بانه احكم السيطره
على عدد من المواقع الاستراتيجيه في
العاصمه الخرطوم ويبدو ان يعني حتى الان
يعني اضافه الى ما جرى في مروي ولكن يعني
المعركه الاساسيه يبدو بين الطرفين
للسيطره على العاصمه لان من يسيطر على
العاصمه بطبيعه الحال تكون لديه يد طوله
في كثير من الامور لذلك نشاهد احتدام
المعارك في هذه
الاوقات بالصوت والصوره نتابعها لحظه
بلحظه على كل من الخرطوم الان مراسل
العربيه سالب الهاشمي ليطلعن على مزيد من
التفاصيل سالم الكلمه لك اين تتركز
المعارك
انواع الاسلحه التي تستخدم وحدود سيطره كل
طرف
لعمل المعركه ما زالت مستخدمه في في المقر
القياده العامه للجيش وكذلك مطار الخرطوم
الدولي هو حتى في محيط القصر الجمهوري
كذلك لكن هذا ياتي بالتزامن مع اعلان حاله
الهدنه التي
اعلنت قبل قليل والدعم السريع قد اصدر
بيانا عقب بيان الجيش من
من القوات المسلحه القوات المسلحه
ذكرت في بيانها انها توافق على مقترح
الامم المتحده بفتح مسارات امنه والحالات
الانسانيه ولمده ثلاث ساعات تبدا من
الساعه الساعه الرابعه عصرا
والا يلغي ذلك حقها الرد عنده لتجاوزات من
قبل الميليشيا المتمرده هذا بيان الجيش
بيانا الدعم السريع عقبه مباشره
من المواطنين الكرام انها وفي اطار طلبه
الامم المتحده ورغبه القوات في تيسير جزء
من حياه الناس تعلن عن السماح للمسارات
الامنه والحالات الانسانيه للمواطنين وذلك
من الان لمده اربع ساعات مع احتفاظنا
بحقنا في حمايه المواطنين في الرد على اي
اعتداء من انقلاب يوم الاشياء النظام
المبارك هذين البيانيين عقب هما مباشره
الرابعه عصر الان ترى في شوارع الخرطوم
هناك انتعاش ولو قليل في حركه لذهاب
المواطنين حتى المحل التجاريه فتحت
بالنسبه لافران الخبز وايضا يلفت الانتباه
ان هناك شعب في الخبز الان هناك طوابير في
صفوف للوصول لشراء الخبز كذلك
افتتاح محلات الثلج لان الكهرباء يعني
منقطعه منذ الامس اكثر من 24 ساعه بدون
كهرباء بكل تاكيد لا وجود المياه البارده
في هذا الصيام فيحتاج الصائمون الى ان
يشتروا الثلج كذلك يعني بدا انتعاشه لو
قليل كما ذكرت لك ليس انتعاش كامل وليس
حركه يعني طبيعيه بالكليه لكن الى حد ما
هناك حركه
تزامنا مع هذا الوقت اطلاق النار
يعني نحن في الطرفان قال انه ما يستجبان
لهذه الهدنه التي طلبتها الامم المتحده
ولكن مع ذلك المعارك في محيط المطار وفي
محيط المقر العام القياده المسلحه على
اشدها يعني كيف يعني يستوي هدان المنطقه
ان المعارك مستمره ولكن نحن موافقين على
هدنه
انها مشروطه بعدم الاعتداء وان هناك رد
للاعتداء فربما هذه المعركه الطاحنه في
القياده العامه الان امام المقر للجيش
السوداني وايضا في مطار الخرطوم كذلك كل
هذه المعارك ينظر اليها بانها اعتداء وانه
في اطار رد الاعتداء فقط وليس اكثر من ذلك
لكن
المواطنون استجابوا الان في الاجزاء
البعيده من مناطق الشده هذه من صحه
العباره وبداوا يعني يستجلبون اهم اغراضهم
واحتياجاتهم بسرعه قبل نهايه
يعني سالم وانت تتحدث اصوات الرصاص يسمع
بشكل جلي يعني مع اضافه الى يعني قد تكون
رصاصات قنص مع بعض القذائف
الصاروخيه سنستمع الى الصوت واعود اليك
سالم ابقى معي
سالم
سالم اذا كنت اسمعني يعني حتى مع اعلان
هذه الهدنه من المشروطه من قبل الطرفين
يعني المعارك على اشدها لا ادري اذا كانت
تسمى
ولكن بالنسبه الى اخر اعداد الضحايا من
قتلى وجرحى من الطرفين ومن المدنيين هل
هنالك اي رقم محدث لديك سالب
نعم متى اعلان ذكرت اليوم لجنه اطباء
انها ذكرت
يعني لها ان
اليوم خمسه اصابات او عدد القتلى خمس من
القتل الذين قتلوا في اشتباكات اليوم ايضا
هذه الاشتباكات ليست في محيطه الجمهوري
وحده بل هي ايضا على الخرطوم
المطار فيه ايضا الاشتباسات عنيفه نتابعها
الان في شرق المطار وكذلك في الجهه
الجنوبيه الغربيه للمطار الان هناك اشتباك
ايضا في هذه المنطقه بين قوات الدعم
السريع والجيش السوداني سالم حدود سيطره
قلت المطار ما زال تحت سيطره الجيش ام لا
يعني في قوات للدعم السريع موجوده داخل
المطار فقط لنشرح للمشاهدين
الطرفين يقول انه يسيطر على المطار
بافادات كل واحد منهم ولكن الجيش السوداني
هكذا انه استعاد مطار الخرطوم بشكل كامل
هناك على تقوم مطار الخرطوم توجد قوات
بالدعم السريع
الشخصيه للمطار في الجهه الجنوبيه للمطار
حتى الجهه الغربيه للمطار في محيط المطار
لقوات الدعم السريع وهناك تاكيدات من
الجيش على انه يسيطر على مطالبه من الداخل
وانه قد طرد الميليشيات المتمرده من مطار
الخرطوم الدولي سالم بطبيعه الحال المطار
مقفل تماما مشلول تماما نتيجه هذه
المواجهات وحدت القصف طيب في ناس
كانوا عندهم رحلات مجدوله يعني في مسافرين
علقوا طب هؤلاء من يتابع اوضاعهم هو خصوصا
يعني سمعنا في عدد من الوفود الصحافيه
عالقه وفي كثير من العمال او رجال الاعمال
الاجانب او المسافرين كانت بجدوله رحلاتهم
ومن ثم الغيت هؤلاء اين يمكثون شو وضعهم
من يتابع اوضاعهم
نعم هذه ايضا من المسائل الانسانيه
المعقده سالم ولكن قبل فقط لاشير اعزائي
المشاهدين وزير الخارجيه السعوديه يؤكد
خلال اتصال مع البرهان واحمدتي على اهميه
العوده للاتفاق الايطالي اذا وزير
الخارجيه السعودي الامير فيصل بن فرحان
يجري اتصالين هاتفيين مع كل من الفريق عبد
الفتاح البرهان ومع الجنرال محمد حمدان
دبلو حماتي وبالطبع يؤكد على دعوه الاطراف
السودانيه للتهدئه وتغذيب المصلحه الوطنيه
اذا هذا اول اتصال من وزير الخارجيه
السعودي
لطرفي النزاع في السودان
والدعوه السعوديه الى التهدئه ووقف كل
اشكال التصعيد العسكري في البلاد اعود
اليك سالم تفضل
نعم هذه المعضله التي ذكرتها وهي مساله
الرحلات والذين كانوا مسافرين
تضج وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي بحملات
اطلقها ناشط في مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
السودانيين يتحدثون عن مفقودين
وكانوا موجودين داخل المطار لم يعرف الى
ذهبوا حتى هذه اللحظه مجموعه منهم وهناك
مجموعات تم الوصول اليهم ومعرفه اماكن
تواجدهم وتم جلائهم ايضا
بشكل هذه هي ابرز المعلومات المتوفره الان
حول هذه القضيه طيب
سالم يبقى معي ساعود اليك بعد قليل ينضم
اليه اعزائي المشاهدين الان من الخرطوم
العضو في حزب الامه القوميه عروه الصادق
سيد عروه اهلا وسهلا بك اولا اريد قراءتك
لمجريات
الامور واين هي المكونات المدنيه في
المشهد السياسي السوداني اين هي مما يجري
لماذا يعني فقط الصوت المسموع هو صوت
الرصاص
خاطبوا فولكر بموافقتهم على فتح مسارات
انسانيه ووقف اطلاق النار ولكن المهدد
الان يا سيدي بهذه حتى هذه الهدنه التي
قيل انها لثلاثه او اربعه ساعات المهدد
ليس ليس الجيوش
المعروفه لدينا جيش الدعم السريع او
القوات المسلحه السودانيه المهدد لها
الجماعه التي اجدت هذه الفتنه فضول النظام
استاذ عروه يعني اذا كان الحديث عن هدنه
والمعارك عم نسمعها يعني
وعم نشوفها على اشدها يعني عن اي هدنه
يجري الحديث عنها وهنا السؤال يعني اللي
اريد ان اطرحه عليك هل هل الامور يعني
وهذا ما يخشى هل الامور ذاهبه باتجاه حرب
اهليه مفتوحه
الى ما لا يعني لا سمح الله ام لا يعني ما
زال هنالك وقت
للمبادرات وللحلول ولجلوس جميع الاطراف
على الطاوله يعني كما يدعو وزير الخارجيه
السعودي الان الامير فيصل بن فرحان في
اتصاله مع الجنرلين احمدتي مع جنرين
البرهان واحمد
مع
استمرار اطلاق سراح الايادي التي عبثت
بالامن والاستقرار في النظام من النظام
البائد ومع استمرار مخطط الفلول الذي برز
جليا لجنرالات الجيش والجنرالات الدعم
السريع
تسير الى
الحرب الخسائر الفادحه في الاشخاص
والمقار والبنت التحتيه كل هذا يمكن ان
يوقف ولكن هنالك محاولات للت
صعيد ان التهدئه وظل ساعات النهار هدوء ما
بين هدوء الى هدوء حذر ولكن فور الاعلان
عن ان هنالك تهدئه موافقه على تهدئه وهدنا
من البرهان وحمايته زادت زخاطر الرصاص هذا
يعني ان هنالك من على الارض يريد تاجييد
هذه الحرب والوصول بها الى مبتغاها
ومبتغاها هو ليس الحرب الاهليه المفتوحه
فقط بل تمزيق اوصال الوطن واعادتنا
للكولتونات
القبليه هي الضيقه وهذا سيفتح الباب لغزو
اجنبي وشيك ونراه ونرى بمن عيوننا تسلل
الجماعات الا المتطرفه حاله فرق عقد الامن
في السودان طيب هل بقي اي شيء من الاتفاق
الايطالي برايك استاذ عروه ام لا هذا
الاتفاق لفظ انفاسه الاخيره وبشكل نهائي
مع اطلاق اول طلقه في هذه المواجهه
اذا اريد لها ان تقطع سبيل الحرب
وتقطع سبيل استمرار الديكتاتوريه في
السودان لن يكون هنالك مسوده يمكن الرجوع
اليها او مشروع يمكن الرجوع اليه الا
الاتفاق الاطاري لانه نابع من سواد اعظم
لابناء وبنات الشعب السوداني واذا ارادت
السلطه القادمه او سلطه الامر الواقعه من
الفائزين سدنه النظام المضاد اذا قد لا
قدر الله الانتصار في هذه المعرفه
الاستحواذ على الدوله حتما
ابقى معي ارجوك يعني فقط لنستمع الى الصوت
وصور الاشتباكات بالصوت والصوره كما تردنا
من الخرطوم تحديدا من مقر محيط مقر
القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه واعود اليك
اذا ما زلنا معكم في هذه التغطيه المستمره
لهذه المواجهات في السودان تحديدا الان
الصور تردنا وبشكل خاص لقناه العربيه من
الخرطوم تحديدا من مقر القياده العامه حيث
تدور اشتباكات عنيفه بين الطرفين في
محاوله للسيطره على المقر ايضا كانت
الاشتباكات محمومه ايضا في محيط مطار
الخرطوم
الدولي الان الرويتس تقول انقطاع البث عن
التلفزيون الرسمي السوداني نتيجه احتدام
هذه المعارك اعود فاذكر اعزائي المشاهدين
بالخبر العاجل الذي اوردناه قبل قليل فقد
اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه ان الوزير
الامير فيصل بن فرحان اجرى اتصالا هاتفيا
مع رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني عبد الفتاح
البرهان كما اجرى اتصالا اخر مع نائب رئيس
مجلس السياده محمد حمدان دقلو واكد وزير
الخارجيه السعودي ضروره التهدئه ووقف كل
اشكال التصعيد العسكري بما يحافظ على
مقدرات السوداء كما شدد الامير فيصل بن
فرحان على اهميه العوده الى الاتفاق
الايطالي الذي يضمن تحقيق الامن للسودان
اعود الى من قطع من حديثي مع السيد عروه
الصادق وهو العضو في حزب الامه القومي كنت
سالتك هل بقي اي شيء من الاتفاق الاطاري
برايك سيد عروه وما يجري الان وما نشاهده
بام العين الا يفتح الباب واسعا لمزيد من
التدخل الدولي في الشان السوداني ونكون
ربما امام سيناريو كسيناريو الليبي مثلا
المرجعيه التي يمكن ان تقولنا الى استقرار
سياسي في السودان والى وصول لمدنيه السلطه
واستعاده مكاسب الثوره السودانيه هي
الاتفاق الاطاري الذي كان يرجى
الوصول الى حلول في قضيته ومعضله الدمج
صباح اليوم الذي اندلعت فيه هذا الواقعه
واللي
لان هذا الطريق واستعاده الانتقال
الديمقراطي سيقطع الباب لعوده النظام
المضاد الى الابد في السودان
ويسهل الوصول الى الديمقراطيه في ختام
الفتره الانتقاليه باجراء انتخابات حره
هذا سيجعل من النظام المضاد نفسيا منسي
لذلك رتبوا صفوفهم منذ يناير المنصرم ونحن
نتابع هذه هذا السيناريو الذي كان مقررا
له ان يندلع في فبراير 19 فبراير من بدايه
هذا العام ولكن حكمه واراده السودانيين
الغلابه والقوه المدنيه تدخلت في وقت حرج
ونصحت قياده الدعم السريع
وخفض ووقف التحشيد في العاصمه حينها سافر
الان محمد حمدان دقله الى الامارات وقضى
زهاء ثمانيه ايام هناك وقال بخطاب بانه
ملتزم بالاطار وايضا حافظ على ذلك الجن
رال ومضينا في المؤتمرات والورش النهائيه
للعمليه الايطاليه ولكن هذا وجهه بتحشيد
وتلغيم الاجواء وادخال عناصر النظام
البايت في القوات المسلحه فحسن طرواده لنص
لنصف العمليه السياسيه طيب هذا الاستاذ
عروه بعد ان اسمح لي بهذا السؤال هل ستكون
سيكون المكون المدني هو المستفيد على
المدى البعيد بفعل هذه المواجهات يعني كون
هذه المواجهات تدور بين المكون العسكري
نفسه
للاسف
الشديد
الشعب المكلوم الذي يرى الان جثث ابناءه
متفحمه في الشوارع لا يستطيع احد اجلائها
ويرى ايضا ان هنالك محبوسون من طلاب
وتلاميذ يعانون
رهاب رهاب شديدا رهاب الحرب كل هذه
المشاهد تتظلف ليست في جبين الذين فتحوا
بل ستظلف وصمه في جبيننا جميعا ابناء امام
ابنائنا وبناتنا الذين لم نستطيع حمايتهم
وان نقدم لهم جرعه
ما الى لا مجال فيه للمزايده او الشماته
من طرف على الاخر نريد الان المضي الى وقف
اطلاق نار فوري وعاجل يريد الان فتحه
الانسانيه وهذا ما ننادي به اخواننا
العسكريين حمله السلاح من كلا الجانبين
ونريد ايضا ان تدعم الاسره الدوليه هذا
التوجه وهذه الوساطه
دول الجوار التي تريد ان تتدخل في السودان
تمنعها من التدخلات الخبيثه التي نراقب
بعضها
مضينا فيه سويا سنجنب بلادنا الشرر
المستطير ونمنع عنها شبح الانزلاق نحو
الحرب الاهليه ونرجع كل من تسوي له نفسه
تمزيق وطنا السودان ونحفظها من التدخلات
والغزو الاجنبي هو دخول عناصر القلوب
والتطرف اليها طيب من الخرطوم العضو في
حزب الامه القوميه عروه الصادق شكرا جزيلا
لك على هذه المشاركه اعود فاذكر اعزائي
المشاهدين الان تؤكد انقطاع البث عن
التلفزيون الرسمي السوداني نتيجه احتدام
المعارك بالطبع المعارك تحتدم كما نشاهد
في محيط مطار الخرطوم وفي محيط مقر
القياده العامه للجيش حيث يمكننا ان نشاهد
بام العين السنت الدخان الكثيف نتيجه
القصف المدفعي بالاسلحه
الثقيله في محاوله من كلا الطرفين للسيطره
على هذين الموقعين الاستراتيجيين على كل
هذه التغطيه مستمره بعد قليل الزميله ابو
غمره تسحبكم في الساعه المقبله اطيب
التحيات والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات